ونشاهد هذه الصور المباشره لتكدس الجثث في
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى بدير البلح بعد
الغارات الاسرائيليه فجر اليوم والتي
اسفرت عن استشهاد نحو 60
[موسيقى]
فلسطينيا شفت هنا اول واحده ج
النصر تعال
تعال
معنا من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح
مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوط هشام اذا ليله
داميه شهدها قطاع غزه كيف يبدو المشهد
الان المشهد هو قصف مستمر لا سما في
المناطق الوسطى والمناطق الشرقيه بالاخص
مخيم البريج ومخيم المغازي يتعرضان ومنذ
يومين او ثلاثه ايام على على الاقل الى
قصف عنيف من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه لا سيما
بعد ان اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي انه بدا
عمليه في المنطقه الوسطى بمعنى دير البلح
والمغازي والبريج والنصيرات والزوايده
وهذه المناطق بدت تتعرض الى قصف عنيف سواء
من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه سواء من الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه مجازر اسرائيليه في
كل يوم وفي كل ليله منذ يومين نحن نرصد
هذه المجازر الاسرائيليه اليوم على الاقل
هناك 35 شهيدا من جراء عمليات قصف
اسرائيلي من الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
التي استهدفت شقق سكنيه ومنازل مدنيه
فلسطينيه ودمرتها وسوتها بالارض على رؤوس
هؤلاء السكان الذين كانوا بداخلها
وبالتالي هناك عشرات من الشهداء يسقطون في
كل ليله وفي كل صباح من جراء عمليات
الاستهداف الاسرائيلي سواء من المدفعيه او
حتى من الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه في
مخيم النصيرات هناك منزلين تم استهدافهما
ونقل عدد من الشهداء والجرحى في ايضا مخيم
المغازي هناك استهداف لمنزل ونقل عدد من
الشهداء والجرحى بالاضافه الى شقق سكنيه
تم استهدافها من الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه لكن ربما في مخيم المغازي
ومخيم النصيرات ايضا في دير البلح كان
هناك استهداف ونقل عدد من الاصابات وعدد
من الشهداء وحتى في الزوايده نقل عدد من
الشهداء والاصابات جراء اكثر من استهداف
اسمح لي بالتنويه بهذا الخبر العاجل نقلا
عن مراسلنا 35 شهيدا اثر قصف اسرائيلي على
منازل في مخيمي المغازي والنصيرات وسط
قطاع غزه منذ فجر اليوم هشام هذه الحصيله
ربما مرشحه
للارتفاع مع صعوبه
انتشال الجثث وايضا الناجين المحتملين من
هذه
الغارات بالفعل في اغلب المرات ومنذ بدايه
هذه الحرب لا يوجد ناجين لان القصف
الاسرائيلي واسرائيل باتت تستخدم قنابل
مدمره وتدمر هذه المنازل على رؤوس السكان
لكن ونحن نتحدث عن 35 شهيدا من مخيمات
المغازي والنصيرات جراء استهداف منازل
مدنيه في ينيه كان يتواجد فيها مدنيون
وايضا عدد كبير من النازحين فحتى النازحون
الذين حاولوا الخروج من هذه المخيمات هربا
من القصف الاسرائيلي الا انهم لم يجدوا
مكانا لا في دير البلح ولا حتى في مدينه
رفح وهذه المناطق التي بات يركز الجيش
الاسرائيلي ويقول للسكان توجهوا الى دير
البلح والى مدينه رفح وبالتالي كل الاماكن
باتت مستهدفه ما عدا دير البلح ومدينه رفح
هذا ليس صحيحا الجيش الاسرائيلي ما يواصل
قصفه لدير البلح
ولمدينة المنطقه الوسطى نحن لم نرصد جلب
او اجلاء اي من المصابين او انتشال اي من
الجثامين من مخيم البريج وهذا لان سيارات
الاسعاف وطواقم الدفاع المدني لم تستطع
حتى الان الوصول الى هذا المخيم الذي
يتعرض الى القصف الاعنف الدبابات
الاسرائيليه ما زالت متوغل في المناطق
المفتوحه في تلك من شرق مخيم البريج
وبالتالي عمليات الاستهداف باتت اكثر
كثافه لا سيما من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
لكن ما زالت هناك محاولات من قبل طواقم
الدفاع المدني للدخول الى المخيم اجلاء
بعض الشهداء وبعض شهود العيان يتحدثون عن
ان بعض الشهداء ملقون على الارض واصيبوا
وظلوا ينزف حتى الموت في تلك المنطقه لا
سياما في المخيمات القريبه او في الاحياء
القريبه او البلوكات القريبه من السياج
الفاصل وهذه المناطق توغلت فيها الدبابات
الاسرائيليه وهي مناطق مفتوحه وحتى الان
تواجه مقاومه ضاريه من قبل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في هذه الاماكن هناك اشتباكات
يسمع اصوات ايضا انفجارات ما بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
المتوغلة
بقصف هذه المناطق منازل مدنيه فلسطينيه
تقصف وتدمر على رؤوس السكان في رفح جنوب
قطاع غزه استهدف الجيش الاسرائيلي ايضا
هناك منزلا ودمره وسواه بالارض وهناك عدد
من الشهداء والجرحى كذلك شكرا لك هشام
زقوت مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا من دير
البلح